hey guys welcome back Garry's Mod scary
map one order a nightmare I'm not even
gonna shoot you stop floating stop
floating why me
yeah okay that I deserve that okay I
probably deserve that i-i-i-i've said
this what seven times up until now but
this is gonna be good Oh shun Oakland
yeah I get ya get out of there
don't you dare don't there let's do this
alright let's do this come on ma get out
of I didn't do you didn't see so so
father that was terrifying
I think everything we've been through up
until this point
oh hell I saw that oh hi I'm going hello
you passed it through a health pack at
me that was awfully nice of it oh my god
bear eating boxes yeah this is the worst
map of all Keys County brayton boxes no
Jerry would start agree to make it in
time yeah sorry I feel bad for his
throat yeah well let's get out of here
what what do you say it's just no jobs
guys some guy usually huh hey let me get
the jump scares
I'm haven't gotten an e you've been
hogging them all I'm sorry me first on
then I thought you first
wah-wah-wah love sprinting now because
it's long oh it's you a merry xmas
events it's fun for all of us that's the
next side way no let me let me go first
hey sorry I'm just I'm really ecstatic
excited oh I really like that sequence a
nightmare that was like one of the best
I was one of the best can you believe
that like we both have played that game
almost two years ago now
oh wow when was it when did you play it
I think that was two years there's with
some frightful little things eh oh my
yeah I couldn't even see what they were
they look like white little worm
laughing they look like why I don't know
what it was no well not going down that
hallway again funny you want me to go
well showing boy it's good nothing oh
okay Wow whoa that was um that was that
that was that all right moving on just
that you guys know that was probably the
scariest in that's happened out of the
last five maps we played oh yeah shaken
er you know event I think we should go
into this fence need to find something
to stack up there are eight boxes in the
other room over yeah that's why you
didn't destroyed us
yeah look I'll follow you
hope I can't wait no there we go
I'm in it all right what's that what's
that what's that oh oh Jesus fail
jumping are you crouch jumping ship yeah
whatever it is for you is it
whatever the buttons honest control
control yeah come on come on come on
come on Youth go bail me man no come on
you can do it I believe in you so bad
come on come on baby you can make it oh
no I'm coming oh it's just bones now Oh
God
oh good gave me some ammo Oh ladder I
seem to be stuck on the boat I seem to
be stuck I'm dead
as you see my body flop down there yes
body's in me body bedded I can't break
him oh I'm moving I'm you okay yeah I'm
just crawling thank you thank you hi hi
there what are you do can't I can't okay
there we go you're good okay okay we
finally find a good one and you break it
fine you know what fine you know you
know I'm sick should turn you're tired
of people don't move
okay Jenny anything up that yes get up
here how do i how do I get know get up
here the ladder
all right don't clips whoa oh god damn
it you're stuck at me I'm sorry what are
you doing I'm really excited you know
what fine you know what fine just get
out of my way
hey Iowa do it my way you you enjoy
yourself over here Wow hello Tyler
alright you know what get over here
stop no clipping okay get out of the
floor okay there we go there we go there
we go okay you know what
yeah if you ruin this for me yeah maybe
the only one I found that actually have
a good you ruined it for me I will I'll
just stand right behind you and I won't
do anything now it's time for the real
nightmare to begin what was it oh it's
still there oh it's still there what
well I don't know if it's still there
it's still there I got it okay they're
just little hairs yeah they're just
little I told you Wyatt things
what the hell yeah okay moving on I'll
press the button over here there we go
what does that do I don't know oh oh oh
rapidly this looks great I'm excited
lovely how was your day today marker uh
what does happen it almost killed me
yeah oh you'd think they'd put some
water or something well this looks nice
what oh you missed it the thing over
hills like some demon thing
oh man I always miss it
well let's go this way there was a door
that was open Abul okay the long hallway
series our long hallways yeah they're
always quite oh wow I'm falling again on
my dog again
woah no I'm alive there's water down
here oh you could kill myself Ito's why
oh you know I'm gonna find out what's in
this room nothing nothing you know where
I'm gonna I'm gonna noclip cuz we got
that vent sequence cuz I don't know clip
is on well sure whoosh welt wowie Zowie
ain't nothing on us yeah man you can
stop it now
really yes okay I'm just back weather
zombie - oh ow
I landed on your head sorry I was trying
about got it
I can't I can't crouch in there get off
of me Hey let me go dying stop no
clipping okay I can't I can't get ya oh
oh there was something in the way hey
what's up I can't get in oh there we go
god I gotta gotta gotta gotta got to get
ya
dad I gotta getta getta getta getta get
to get to get to get to get down I'm
ready so Andy Dana why'd you expect to
happen I don't say there'll be a jump
scare of a
a zombie he's gonna jump up in front of
us okay I go wow I was wrong it was
invisible though Oh visible zombies
aren't scary
Jerry move oh there we go
ranking Jerry every time she just like
oh hello invisible in busy somebody's
yeah are you still here good yeah I'm
behind you
hi good haters this OS like jeez this is
a long hallway it's event whatever same
thing what event it's a long vent way
it's a very long vent way filled with
water that's a great thing we don't need
to breathe because we don't have lungs
mm-hmm there we go ah glad we went all
that way
ya know how much help me you don't
either
help please can I get out I'm not gonna
no no no I can't swim
yeah Jim oh wow it's too bad you can't
do something to make you walk through
walls
there we go there you go there you go
good good good job thank you good job
there shmurda boy go Oh what I figured
that one out what happened I hit these
guys always they're invisible remember
something they're everywhere
oh my oh that's why I'm using a gun
alright there's more here um there's one
very nice since I'll be dying
okay BAM [ __ ] mmm hey Mark
it looks like fried chicken no that
looks like fried chicken all right let's
go on okay nope
what's not apparently I'm supposed to
jump into this whoop oh it's a swimming
hole really it took you that long to
notice are you dumb
is there anything by oh look another
vent oh man yeah I love then I wished
upon a star there would be another vent
I'm gonna just shoot preemptively
because I'm not gonna yeah I'm not gonna
die cuz I'm tired open up and we will
fall to our demise that would be
expected it sure would be you hair a
hair now anything
1 I'm dead oh how alive and I am dead Oh
ya'll say this is great I wish you a
hair yeah at the rave party wherever the
hell that is hang on I'm gonna try and
find you I gotta get back because I got
a I got a trace the vents all the way
back exactly 10 HP which is how much HP
good yeah thanks
you're so nice oh wait I think I see I
think oh I see I see I see I see I see
where you felt that is a long one yeah
I'm coming
any second now it's actually slower to
noclip than it would be to fall yeah
it's full I'm too already there I'm
already here
yeah I'm glad I'm back too because this
place is kind of messed up Wow I know
I'm asking what it was
Lombe really are you gonna be able to
find your way back
I'll try I'm gonna try to go forward a
bit see if I can find some I'm trying to
find you right now I'm gonna train Oh
jaysus what have I done to the game oh
my god if only there was a teleport
mechanic like in Minecraft I'll be good
I would do that you would but you can't
I know it's a door to nothing so this
might end the game yeah I'm that because
I was I was lost in wait nothing I was
actually pretty cool it wasn't bad
dragged on a bit with the really long
sequences events but yeah I agree
stone as good as one any place you in
whoa yeah will whoa bye well I'm just
kidding I'm just abstraction I'm just
glad I'm know I'm done you're done I'm
done
yeah you guys you should definitely
watch the one of my challenge really
good bit click on his face or something
oh no